das gibt's doch es gibt auch sonova die
skatenight lag vielleicht auch von mir
also so was halt gibt es auch eine immer
gut aufpassen
etwas knapper als willkommen bei einem
neuen video und ich denke jetzt um die
schon gelesen es geht heute darum als
ich kriege als sehr auf die frage woran
merkt eigentlich dass ein junger mich
mag oder was irgendwie toll finde nur
dass ein junger mich auf jeden fall
bekomme ich auf die frage stellt woran
merke ich eigentlich dass ein junger
interesse an mir hat beim erst mal
drüber nachdenke habe ich mir so gedacht
keine ahnung aber wenn man halt mal
bisschen länger darüber nachdenkt und
das auf sich bezieht also mich jetzt
schon was eingefallen ich will gar nicht
lange gelagert und ich würde sagen wir
fangen einfach wieder malen und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß falls ja fast
noch nach oben da also wenn sich
gemeldet hätten sonst nicht sonst doch
noch und werden es sehr wichtig finde
ich war dann weiß ich ob es euch gefällt
oder nicht ob wir mehr davon wollte oder
nicht ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach
mit so etwas sehr selbstverständliche
man auf jeden fall wenn ihr alten jungen
toll findet und von ihnen nachricht
bekommt wisst ihr automatisch dass ihr
euch auf teufeln aber wenn ihr halt als
mädchen den jungen angeschrieben hat ein
bisschen schreibst du normalerweise aus
höflichkeit anderen wirklich jeder und
wenn ihr aber wirklich nur über ihn
anschreiben ist und er euch danach nicht
auch mal schreibt könnt ihr es
eigentlich vergessen deswegen hast du
ganz allgemein verfasst wenn euch ein
junger also wenn ihr mit einem jungen
schreibt aber ihn antreiben ist dann
bringt das gar nichts klingt vielleicht
hat aber das ist halt so wirklich
nächste sache
das hab ich auch so ein bisschen auf
mich bezogen und zwar also wie gesagt
wir gehen jetzt gerade schon mal davon
aus ihr habt schon so ein bisschen
kontakt mit den jungen wie ihr in
kontakt von habe ich letztens ein video
zu macht findet ihr auch auf dem carl
von mir aber erst später verlinkt ja nun
machen auch die etwa weiter und zwar ich
gehe zeit immer schon so davon aus dass
ihr so ein bisschen kontakt wenigstens
zudem junger fleisch stufe oder klasse
keine ahnung und zwar das ist auch so
habe ich auch jetzt so auf mich bezogen
das ist ohne scheiß so wenn man halt
irgendwie ein ganz cool findet und etwas
mit der person macht zum beispiel weiß
ich nicht irgendwo lang laufen einfach
als dummes beispiel und überall sind ja
eigentlich irgendwelche fensterscheiben
oder irgendwie sowas wo man sich selber
drin sieht und dann wenn man halt gut
aussehen und manz opfers ein bisschen
herum dass er alles gute
macht man so oder so
und ja so ist das halt deswegen wenn ihr
als mädchen jetzt mit irgendeinem jungen
durch die gegend läuft und er die ganze
zeit so weit denkt nicht bist du
behindert sondern der markt wohl jetzt
beim nächsten punkt da war ich mir
unsicher ob ich das bereinigen soll oder
nicht weil ich hab's glaube ich schon 21
mal in meinen videos gesagt aber wir
machen es einfach mal ganz kurz und zwar
heutzutage gibt es ja instagram facebook
was gibt es noch immer viel spaß und so
was alles und zwar wenn ein junge den
ihr vielleicht ganz cool findet nicht
ein foto von euch live weil eins ist
immer so ja kommt das leid ich einfach
mal so aus höflichkeit oder aus weißt du
nicht mein job ist auch scheißegal auf
jeden fall wenn ein junger halt zehn
fotos von euch leid können direkt davon
ausgehen okay der findet mich an toll
weil sonst wird man keine zehn fotos
leiten okay ich vielleicht gibts nur
notwendigen ja das gibt's doch es gibt
auch so not quite like lag vielleicht
auch von mir also so was halt gibt es
auch immer gut aufpassen
okay wir machen direkt weiter und zwar
das ist jetzt also der nächste punkt
dass es eigentlich so eine bestätigung
von der bestätigung dass ihr euch mal
und zwar wenn ihr vielleicht schon mit
dem jungen schreibt oder so und er euch
im handy jetzt nicht einfach so chantal
ein speichert sondern chantal vielleicht
fekter plant q
das ist nicht gut ihr wisst schon was
ich meine irgendwie so einen schwulen
smiley dahinter oder ich weiß es nicht
keine ahnung irgendwann als süßer name
auch wenn das eben gesehen aber das ist
auf jeden fall eine bestätigung weil man
spreche denn nicht einfach so
irgendjemanden anders sein als wir
richtig heiß wenn man ihn nicht mag wenn
man ihn nicht mehr als mal bei mir ist
jetzt zum beispiel hier
sandra kehren eisberg gucke ich hier ein
mit meinem besten kumpel habe ich nicht
eingespeichert wir heißt sondern eisbär
damit sei ihm dass ich ihn ganz toll mal
ein spaß ich habe ihn so eingespeichert
weil seine freundin heißt ja und jetzt
kommt noch ein sehr wichtiger punkt es
kann ja nämlich auch sein dass ihn auch
gar kein kontakt zu dem jungen ab also
ihr seht euch vielleicht ab und zu aber
ihr habt ihr redet nie miteinander guckt
euch auch nicht wirklich an obwohl da
ist dann halt schon so auf jeden fall
wirklich jetzt mal davon aus sie hat
kein kontakt richtig da kann ich
verraten euch mein video fünf schritte
ein mädchen jungen klar zu machen ist
auf jeden fall super ist am ende auch
verlinkt und so geht das nach dem video
hier anzuschauen und gebt euch das nach
dem video anzuschauen keinen sinn aber
wir an sich herausfindet ob ein junge
den ihr wirklich gleich ob in dem mit
dem ihr gar nicht kommuniziert ob er
interesse an euch hat oder nicht das
einzige was ich sagen würde ja wenn euch
manchmal so anguckt nicht was aber so
blicke und so vielleicht aber sonst
keine ahnung sonst geht das gar nicht
aber kann ich habe keine ahnung wie das
sonst gehen soll ich weiß es nicht
könnte ja in die kommentare schreiben
wenn irgendein tipp oder soja ansonsten
will ich sagen daumen nach oben ist ja
natürlich immer gut instagram und so war
eben auch schon eine meinung steht aber
auf jeden fall in der video beschreibung
und ich habe ja gesagt hier dieses fünf
schritte ein mädchen junge lara klar zu
machen findet ihr hier oben eigentlich
eine check das auf jeden fall ab hört
mich freuen und abonnieren ich vergessen
auch nichts zu verpassen wir sehen uns
am mittwoch wieder hunderte auf 15 uhr
einschalten heftig